first of all um congrats again on season
4 I've seen the first seven episodes and
Fu for not giving me eight nine and
10 you're welcome it's all by Design
yeah we're still doing uh there's visual
as you know our finales our last few
episodes are always very big so this
season is no exception yeah I think this
is what you did last time where like the
last episode or two just wasn't
for send out yeah right uh so where are
you in post on 8 n and 10 well as you
know because the visual effects usually
takes the longest that's the process
we're still kind of finalizing and
trying to get into shape um but you know
the the strike kind of threw off the
schedule a bit and and so we're lucky we
have time now to really finish it right
and music sound stuff like that but but
we're hoping to get those out to you
guys uh before the before the premere
so that's that's the hope not the season
not episode one probably by the end of
the year but yeah it's I think you'll I
think you're gonna I think you're gonna
love it were you actually that's a legit
thing I'm about to ask you so obviously
when the strike was happening you could
not work on the show how scared were you
about the release of the show with the
strike and not being able to tweak
things that you might want to tweak you
know we we were lucky enough that we had
sort of finished the editing process
basically by the time the strike
happened so a lot of the heavy lifting
was done um and so you know there was a
bit of a concern just in terms of how
long visual effects takes to you know
get that photo real look that's so
important to our show um but uh we were
able to uh you know our B visual effects
team was able to kind of keep the ball
rolling uh and uh we're lucky to be able
to premere it when we are so I ask you
this question every time we talk might
as well ask you it this time uh when am
I getting a
Starship season 13 or 14 Matt I don't
know it's somewhere on our timeline but
it's uh really deep deep down I mean
we're getting closer you have to admit
every season I mean it's it's an
interesting thing you know uh I don't
know why but recently I'd watched like a
scene from season one and it's it's such
a different the show has evolved so much
from then and I think as you see every
season it's kind of becomes more science
fiction so the the things that in the
beginning of the the when we started the
show so much of our research was based
on real designs real plans like we you
know this happened looking at like the
blueprints of the Sea Dragon now we've
gone to the point now where like all our
researchers and and you know Consultants
they're like arguing with each other
over wait is this the way it would be
it's all theoretical at this point a lot
of it you know I mean we still try to
maintain some tie to science and but the
science we're dealing with now is
science that's some of it's kind
of go being explored right now in our
current time and some of it has not even
been explored yet so I think we the show
as it continues going on it sort of
becomes more you know theoretical and I
think that challenge is interesting um
because we know for Matt and I I think
it's really important to maintain a very
grounded show you know that the show
feels grounded and the further we go
into the future the harder is to
accomplish listen I think that there's
this place um called NASA and other
space places that I am confident are all
watching your show now and that's what I
wanted to ask you have you gotten
messages from like blue origin like Jeff
Bezos and like Elon and NASA and people
that are clearly interested in the space
race and outer space um like you know
emailing and saying blah blah blah or
you know what I mean yeah no we
definitely hear as especially through
Garrett Ryman our uh uh one of our
technical advisers a former astronaut a
lot of the you know he's obviously was
with NASA for a long time and then was
sort of the head of the uh the SpaceX
space division for or the man space
flight uh part of spacex's uh program
for a long time and is still connected
with that so we hear through a lot of uh
uh secondhand through him like the Kelly
brothers are really into the show and
stuff like that I I haven't heard
anything from Bezos or musk personally
they haven't emailed me yet but I'm
waiting I'm my email inbox is waiting
for their their messages uh got it the
getting back to the Starship so in I
don't want to do spoilers but in season
4 going to Mars is sort of now like just
flying to Boston from La you know like
the drama is been solved if you will so
talk a little bit about that like now in
season 4 how long does it take from I
forget the because I think you said it
is it like 30 days from Earth to Mars
right yeah 30 days and and you know the
moon which used to take three days to
get to is now like is is you can get
there in less than a day and I think
that was something that was really
important for us in in the way that you
know flight on the planet Earth evolved
from something that was very risky to
something that was very commonplace and
safe uh we felt like space would take
that same
trajectory and uh become much more
commonplace and safe and there aren't
all these you know obviously our show is
filled with a lot of space accidents for
dramatic purposes but uh in in season 4
it's really
become uh commonplace and there are
monthly trips to Mars because the amount
of workers on the planet has grown so
much um and that obviously necessitated
having different types of engines with
the ships uh you know plasma and ion
engines which have never been tested in
space really but are uh theoretically
possible and have been you know
prototypes have been developed here on
Earth um and that constant acceleration
will just shrink the timeline so now in
season 3 you had to wait two years when
Mars and Earth were sort of in the
optimal position uh to to have the
shortest um
Transit time now you can launch wherever
you know you just every month there's
another uh uh transport ship to to Mars
coming back and forth although I say
just to put my nerd hat on like it's 30
days is the best case scenario obviously
the you know it changes depending on
when you launch how close Earth is to
Mars so it I'm not going to get into it
now but yeah 30 days is sort of our best
the closest window um you can do one of
the things is talk a little bit about
how much do you want the show to deal
with the ramifications of someone being
in space for years you know because I
don't I'm not a scientist but I I have
read or heard that if you're like in
outer space for years uh even with
gravity it's still going to do a number
to your body yeah no it's um it is
something that the show has sort of had
to tackle more and more now that we have
people up there for so much longer um I
think Ed Baldwin is probably the
character the most amplifies that uh
impact it's something that we we you
know researched a lot about as well in
terms of like what are the impacts of
living on that planet for that long and
I think the biggest thing is radiation
right that's the biggest risk like the
more radiation exposure you have
obviously the more dangerous over time
so it became interesting that the older
you are though the less of a risk really
in a way not not less of a risk of
radiation but less of a risk of lifespan
to have to deal with that so I think
it's something where you know in the I
don't want to spoil anything but in the
construction of the base it's something
we also took into question like okay
well how do you limit radiation like if
there is you know how do you limit the
exposure as much as possible is a big
thing and then physically in terms of
movement it's also something that as you
get older it may be in certain ways
easier to be on Mars than on Earth
because the pressure of gravity is less
so for someone like Ed Baldwin who's
older I think if he was on Earth it
would be a lot harder on him to walk
around than it is on Mars I think that
there's there's the the pros and cons of
living I think in that kind of
environment yeah I could go real geeky
and say are they building with like UV
bounce in the ceiling you know all that
stuff but what do you guys actually want
to tease fans about season 4 that is not
in the trailer or in the trailer I think
um what was most exciting to us to delve
into in season for in a way that we had
not yet in the previous seasons is this
idea of who gets to go to space because
in the first three seasons and in our
real timeline really uh almost everyone
that has gone to space has been a pilot
or a scientist an
engineer uh people that have trained
their whole lives for that purpose um
and uh we felt like in the evolution of
of our show and sort of the uh the idea
of uh mining for resources planets like
you and and these large scale building
projects you wouldn't just be bringing
pilots and scientists and Engineers
you'd be bringing construction workers
and Miners and and uh uh you know people
that that uh have a different skill set
that space is not necessarily their
natural habitat if you will and um so
that was really interesting to bring in
characters uh in in um miles Dale and uh
Samantha and some other people that that
you meet as the season goes on who uh H
are sort of normal people who are just
looking to make a living support their
families Advance their careers but it's
more of a sort of a blue collar element
whereas there's the sort of rarified air
of the astronauts and cosmonauts uh and
that Dynamic how those people interact
together we find really interesting when
you guys talked about a while every
season you've talked about how you had a
road map that you came up with a while
ago that you were sort of walking down
so how far had you thought about the
road map and are we starting to get to a
place where the road map is no longer
written we had a very ambitious road map
I would say um you know early on we
planned this out over six or seven
seasons so we're still on the road map
and you know I'm proud to say that we've
stuck to I think the big goalposts we'
had so far obviously there are changes
every season and we leave you know the
writers and the writers room flexibility
to go off the map if we have to or make
changes um but right now I mean we're
interested we're sort of like past the
halfway point in a way you know and it's
fascinating that I think you know as in
most TV shows in the beginning you dream
of like oh I see this Big Arc as
ambitious as we were I don't think at
that moment we really felt we were like
oh yeah for sure let's talk about what's
going to happen in season six of the
show but here we are you know premiering
season 4 and it's incredible to see the
kind of the the opportunity we've had
not only to show how you know the show
is Advanced and technology advanced on
the show but how these characters have
evolved that now you're seeing their
children um and even their children's
children so it's sort of that
opportunity makes the show really unique
and I think I think that the hope is to
be able to take that story all the way
to the present time I think that was
always you know for me
a goal of how amazing it would be to see
to get to the present of our alt history
and kind of see how different the world
could have been I think that that's
something we really we're really looking
forward to see my thing is I'm and this
is me spitballing and pardon me as I say
this but so my my question is is it
possible that For All Mankind go six
seven seasons with your original plan
and then there is a spin-off show that
goes like 200 years later where it all
of a sudden becomes a version of Star
Trek and you're like you you know You'
glossed over how you got to the um the
warp engine if you will but somehow in
those 200 years you did and all of a
sudden Ron Moore is now oh
[Laughter]
yeah apple are you
listening Steve's got a
pitch I mean look that that's what's
cool about um this universe is that it's
kind of um
like there are so many different
possibilities so many ways you could go
so many different stories you can tell
within this universe of For All Mankind
that we really from that butterfly
moment of the Soviets beating us to the
moon the way we view it is it's a whole
new universe that keeps getting more and
more different and so you know it's
really blue skies I think in terms of
the potential for the uh uh storytelling
going forward yeah I only say this
because I know the way contracts work
and you know after seven seasons if you
want to go to another like it's a whole
mess of a thing so that's why I was
saying For All Mankind is like the
prequel show to the right you know
whatever the Star Trek show is right I
love it I think I think right now we're
just focusing on let's getting season
five launched no no I'm messing with you
but I I'm just thinking about this yeah
no I listen I think we're ambitious we
definitely are hungry to tell more of
the story and we think like Matt said
there's there's an opportunity with this
show that we built a world a unique
world and I think the key to that to
however far we go is how do you keep it
grounded I think that was what was
always so fascinating to us about this
concept was yes it's sci-fi but we
wanted to feel very grounded sci-fi we
you know and I think the the the
struggle of jumping that much in time is
how do you still maintain um the tone
and the feel for all mankind if you were
to do something like that you know and I
think that's something we're facing
right now even with season 4 you know a
lot of it comes back to how would it
truly feel to build a colony on Mars
what would be the actual issues you'd
have to deal with the moral dilemmas
that's that's what goes into our
thinking with the show and I think
something we really try to hold on to
even if we're getting further and
further into the the El history so do I
I I'm look I always look at the Apple
top 10 uh to see like what's in there
and For All Mankind is in there a lot
you know it's mostly always in the top
10 so has Apple told you um we're really
happy does again and I think I've asked
is does Kim Tim Cook watch the show or
any Executives because that will help
keep it on the air we've heard nothing
but really positive things from Apple
and how the show's doing for them and uh
I think they're really happy and um you
know both with how it's doing in terms
of viewers and how it's doing creatively
and uh
um I don't know necessarily which people
are watching it or not uh or which which
ones it's on their the the top of their
list but it's uh you know everybody
seems really happy with it we've heard
we have fans in copertino that's that's
as far as that's
true well I'm going to say and I've said
this many times I think apple and I'm
gonna I'll say it straight up they are
making the best sci-fi that's on
television right now uh between your
show and Silo and you know Monarch which
is coming out soon like everything
they're doing sci-fi related um is
fantastic yeah I agree honestly I think
that the uh that that
uh the quality level of Apple overall is
really strong like you just can tell
that there's a a level of uh of thought
behind their shows that that it really
um we've felt in working with them that
that uh there's a high expectation level
for what they put on the air what shot
or sequence in the four seasons was the
back breaker um where you you wrote it
but didn't realize what it was actually
going to entail
man that's a good question there are so
many I feel like we deal with that every
every season um I will say even in this
first episode of Season 4 there's a
sequence in the middle that was very
challenging I think as you when you
watch it you will know what sequence I'm
talking about but it's you know it's
it's seeing you know our stunt
team is unbelievable you know um they we
so we in the room come up these insane
ideas every season and I think because
we see they can pull it off we go
crazier and crazier every season I feel
like in terms of what we want to
accomplish I think a big thing for us is
not to repeat ourselves so you know a
lot of the action sequences this year
are very challenging they were very
challenging I think they they challenged
our crew more than any other season
before but we really pulled it off I
think you know and I think the the the
actors being able to put themselves in
the harnesses and put themselves through
that in these huge bulky suits is not
easy but I think for for me that that
scene in the middle of SE of episode 4
is was incredibly challenging and
something we worked on you know I mean
the visual effects there are something
we worked on for a while too to really
get that right so the key is you know
with everything like that you you never
want to think beyond the scene and the
action and the drama of the moment but
what goes behind that is so much stunt
work so much visual effects so much
acting that you really need to pull
something complicated like that off and
that's just one episode you know I mean
you could look at this first episode and
go it's a huge action movie and then we
got nine more to go so I think for us it
was great on one hand in the writer room
when we had this concept it was like oh
my God this is gonna be amazing but then
uh pulling it off was a real challenge
I'm curious if I can ask about the
writing because you obviously how much
are you in your mind saying okay well
look every season first episode we got
to make sure we have some action thing
in it to hook people back in and then
the finale we have to have some sort of
big action thing to sort of you know
like how much is that in your writing
process because you also only have so
much money to spend that you can only do
sequences like that at certain points in
the season so how much is it the first
episode and the last episode are going
to get money and then we're going to do
one other one maybe episode five or
whatever it might be or does that not
enter the the brain it does to a certain
degree uh like I think we always think
about how can we sort of grab people at
the beginning it doesn't have to
necessarily be a big action set piece uh
per se but we really want to kind of
plant our flag
on uh what type of season this is going
to be and really have uh something
emotional happen and something dramatic
that tees up the season in a big way um
and then you know the way we tell
stories uh tends to build to a
climax um but on the flip side of that
we are always constantly aware of the
audience's expectation and so if if our
show is falling into a expectation of
well we know in the first and the last
episode it's going to be big action
setpiece and then everything in the
middle is is nothing uh it's just you
know character work and and drama you
know we we want to try to find ways to
undermine that or take you in a way
you're not going to expect to go um
so it's always a balance between those
things but we're definitely thinking
about it all the time so when looking at
some of my questions so how big is the
writer room on this series and has how
much has it changed how many people have
been there besides you two since the
beginning who are still writing on it I
mean we've had we've been fortunate to
have some people with us from the
beginning the but you know as the show
has evolved so is the writers room I
think we' brought in new people um as
the show has gone on but I think it's
it's it's it's sort of an interesting
metaphor for the show itself right like
you as the show grows we want to bring
in new voices and those voices have
helped tell these new stories as we've
gone on so uh even just like our cast
and crew there are people that have been
with us since the beginning us
Old-Timers and then there are people who
are kind of coming in to freshen things
up but the room I think right now we're
at about man it's I want to say about
eight writers right and uh and yeah it
was interesting you know we we kind of
have to do the zoom Zoom room thing last
season which is also uh not the most fun
thing in the world um because you lose
those little moments but I think because
we have such a good relationship with
the writers and we know each other so
well because we've done this for so long
there's a shorthand where I think the
zoom isn't as impact as it would be on
another show you know we we kind of know
the show we know the tone and we know
each other so I think it's just it's
honestly a lot of fun to kind of get
back in the room with everyone and and
work things out what is it like the
first day so you for example season 4
you it's the first day of the writer
room I guess you're doing a zoom thing
what is it actually like that day how
much does the staff know about your
overall vision of the show the six seven
season plan like what is it like that
first day um they definitely know uh the
vision they've all seen uh the the uh
you know when we used to meet in person
we had uh around uh the room there was
like a timeline laying out a lot of the
events uh and it even you know it was a
a huge writer room uh in terms of space
and it went all the way around just
because we we mapped it out so long um
now it's just on on a screen but uh what
a lot of times will happen is Ben and I
will um take sort of the morning to lay
out a lot of the things we've already
thought about prior to the room and lay
out some story arcs that we're thinking
of and some new characters we want to
try to bring in and it's a lot of talk
about uh themes we want to touch on and
kind of um how we see the the world of
the show
evolving um if we've had any thoughts
about major life events that may have
happened in Cara characters lives
between Seasons but it's always a kind
of a jumping off point nothing is set in
stone because we really feel it's
important to have the first few weeks of
the room be like a blue skies anything
is possible best idea wins kind of
free-for-all of just a fun discussion
there's a lot of of um storylines we go
down for a couple of days that wind up
not coming to fruition at all um and but
that's not really wasted time because
you're still you're getting to know
these characters again and you're kind
of getting to wrap your mind around
where they are at in their lives and um
um because we think so much in depth
about the characters lives and the world
I think it that's that trickles down
into the episodes later a lot of that
work we do early on how many of the
scripts do you normally have done before
you start filming oh man in the
beginning we always plan to have all of
them done before we start and that never
happens yeah I mean I think you know the
goal is always to have as many as
possible so you're not writing while
you're shooting that goal on every TV
show we've ever worked on I think that's
always the goal and I don't think it
ever happens that you have every script
before you start shooting so usually
ends up being in some version mat ey on
set in the back corner in the dark room
with a laptop hunched up working on a
script towards the end of the season it
happens every season we're all and when
we start a new season we're like how do
we avoid that what can we do to avoid
being in that situ and literally the
same thing happens every year so I don't
know if it's a TV thing where you know
you you kind of wait till you use the
time you have maybe that's kind of what
it is as a writer but it's something we
try we try to improve on every year so
season four uh you gave it away in the
poster uh is about mining an asteroid so
who came up with the I was this in the
original like idea the six seveny year
plan that we'd eventually get to an
asteroid and we'd mine it definitely we
we have always been interested in the
idea not only of mining asteroids but
the idea of harnessing and moving
asteroids which is such a kind of a
mindblowing concept that there's
actually been a lot of thought and um
and uh theories bandied about how you
might do that um and so from season one
we knew that we wanted to kind of uh um
head in that direction because mainly
we've always wanted to ground space Trel
in it's not just about exploration
because exploration only gets you so far
a lot of the the uh Roots behind
exploration are for resources you're
exploring things to find resources and
the asteroid belt is the sort of the the
gold mine of the solar system you know
like there is so much valuable uh stuff
in them Hills over there um and so we uh
we're we've been ing inged by this idea
of as the space uh program space
exploration
expands and it becomes more about like
wow these resources that are just so
rare on Earth but are abundant in space
how would that impact um how people
behave and how countries behave to each
other and what's the new race for those
you know that becomes what the space
race is is the race for resources
and for riches so we talked a lot in the
room about like The Treasure of the
Sierra Madre and and a lot of westerns
where this idea of how greed and uh uh
sort of competition for wealth can
impact human beings season 4 opens with
uh another Montage uh which I know you
guys both love and Dread putting
together um so what is for because you
what do you what do you want to tease
people about that
Montage uh are there any like shots that
go by really fast that you should keep
an eye out on oh you know we have those
um I think um it's interesting this
year's Montage because I was noticing
how much of the Montag is now alt
history you know I think in the past we
used the montages away like we do the
music to kind of settle you in the era
in that year whereas this year I felt so
much of it was uh alt history and it
really showed how much the butterfly
effect had had impacted our our world so
the moments of actual history are few
and far between and maybe moments that
we that we felt would stand out in ways
that we think would be funny and
entertaining but you know it's it's
interesting that that even even as a
montage piece it doesn't it doesn't only
set the table there are story points in
there that set up the season you know so
I think when you talk about those little
moments I I do think it's the kind of
thing you want to watch in real time and
then later if you have the time and the
wherewithal it would be worth your while
to look through slowly because there are
little Easter eggs throughout um and
yeah like you said it's it's it's all I
always feel when we make this thing it's
a mini documentary we're doing on the
side of For All Mankind and we're
literally doing it as we're shooting the
show and writing the show like there's
this this thing continuing on and the
legal process and it I mean it's such a
collaborative and complex process but in
the end we really happy with this one I
think this year's is probably the best
one so far what ends up being the most
challenging part of making the show that
fans might not expect I would say uh for
me personally it's the news reports
because so much thought has to go
into
um the writing of the news reports but
also building out the world in a way
that you know a lot of those uh bonus
reports that are done um the the sort of
the the yearly news reports that are
aired before the season so much thought
goes into the alternate history of that
and then the writing of that that then
and I joke all the time about how our
our dream is to write like a cop
procedural where you don't have to think
about you know the like what happened in
Germany in in uh you know 1998 and like
just all these things that that we have
to put our brain power into
that's fun but it's also very
challenging and it and as a writer it's
very um uh you know there's a special
Cadence to writing for a news anchor
that it it there's it's very easy to not
feel real and so it's uh that's
something that I think is challenging in
a way that maybe is not as glamorous as
some of the other stuff that's
challenging what do you want to tease
people about Toby keble's role on season
4 uh and his character's Journey this
was the big new character this season
and I think for us like Matt said
earlier a lot of it was how do we
capture the idea of the every man
someone who is struggling on Earth to
make a living where their opportunity
now in Mars in our alt alt history to
help support his family so I feel like
Toby when we casted him we knew I mean
we we have been a fan of his for years
from his previous work he has this to
really
um like just become the character in a
way that is uncanny um and he took this
he really took on this role in a way
that embraced not only the struggles of
the guy in the beginning but then seeing
his wonder and going up to this new
world so it to me it always felt the
possibility of having that perspective a
different perspective for the for the
first time on this show of someone going
to Mars not to do research not to
explore but to make a
living you know and I think that that's
the thing that I think I'm most excited
about this season really is is both Toby
but you have all these other characters
up there to make a living for their
families back home which really tells
you one about how much space travel has
changed how much it's become normalized
in a way and I think really a a dividing
point of this show right now of where
we're headed is more in a world where
because space travel is more normalized
not only the kinds of people that go to
but what they're doing when they go up
there you know and I think being away
from his family but also having to learn
the rules of the the game up there is
one of the central arcs of the of the
season and you know look I think the
other nature of the show is that we
bring in new faces every season right we
have some of old cast remain and just
like we brought in Deva with Eddie gagi
last season I think Toby came in to play
this role I think for the show to
continue the idea is that we'll be
bringing in these new faces every season
while keeping some of our previous
characters from previous season so it's
not such a huge change from season to
season you're seeing kind of the the
slower baton Paths of the show um
happened well one of the things about
the show is you don't introduce people
that like quickly dis like he's a real
actor tal really talented actor so my
question is when you're casting someone
like this and I don't want to say
anything about his journey through the
seven episodes I've seen but you are
introducing new things For All Mankind
involving his character and it could be
an arc that goes for a long time
because of what things I can't say so my
question is you know is it safe to
assume that Toby is not a one season
character and this is a bigger thing
that you're introducing to outer space
spoiler alert yeah uh I I would say that
we definitely approach that character uh
with the point of view of wanting them
to be a
multi-season character and miles to kind
of be a new presence that grows with the
Mars colony um and I think uh when we
were casting uh one of the things we
were really looking for was
versatility uh and breadth of of
experience as an actor that that they've
played different types of roles because
people evolve and change and I think uh
what's great about Toby is that he's
played like if you look at his character
in that black mirror episode which is
fantastic versus rock and rolla or some
of the other things like he's played so
many different types of characters or
ins servant that we knew he had that
breth of ability to tell the the kind of
the longer Arc of Miles Dale as a
character yeah I don't want to get into
specifics but um but it's it's cool
because it's a completely different side
of For All Mankind that is being
introduced to the to the series so with
Edward Baldwin how old is he in season
four how old do you think he is in
season four no uh
he I think I think uh right now he's in
his early 70s I don't like to say
specific number because then people jump
all over the number but I have to give
uh Joel kinaman credit this season that
he embraced fully the aging process in a
way that Matt and I really appreciated
like he not only sitting in a makeup
chair for four or five hours a day
putting on prosthetic so he'd be there
like 2 three in the morning on a workday
putting on the Prosthetics but then you
know the way he move I think the things
people don't appreciate as much and and
maybe they're starting to is the way he
moves The Voice the little things put he
he lost 30 pounds of muscle this season
of what you know for this role so you
talk about an actor who commits to the
part there's no one like like him in my
view in terms of really being able to
take on the aging and and embracing it
um I think Ren Schmidt is another one
she she fully takes it on you know she
she understands that this she understood
from early on if we're going to tell the
story of someone's lifetime then you
have to show that process of Aging
happening so I think I think you know
sometimes we get lost a little bit in
what is their age and what is the number
and what you know how old are they for
us more than anything it's about change
right it's about Evolution the idea of
if you look at Joel or Ed Baldwin in
season 1 and Ed Baldwin season 4 you
understand how much that guy has changed
and aged and I think the real tale is
when you meet our actors in real life
which happens a lot people are always
thrown by by how young they look um I
think that's that that's a testament to
our makeup team that you know they do
the kind of makeup that sometimes is
subtle sometimes it's like where we put
a wrinkle I can't even tell you how much
time we put into like where is that
wrinkle and where do we put the Aging
spots and what are the age spots and how
do it's a it's a the whole other side of
For All Mankind that that's happening
all the time and and really is is quite
challenging and the actors we're
thankful that we have the actors that
embrace it you know they embrace it
fully is this obviously if he's in his
70s he still has possible time but are
we nearing the end of the Edward Baldwin
Arc of For All Mankind or is he someone
who could survive into being a 100 or
110 we can't answer that come on Steve
there's no way answering that never know
what space do it's untested Waters who
knows what impacts on
longevity uh space might have sure I
won't I won't pressure I you know got to
go for some curveballs so showrunners
tell me that when every season of a show
they get to build a new set or they get
to build a little bit of some new stuff
because that you get to so what did you
get to build in season 4 that you can
tease people well the irony of our show
is that it's almost like a new show
every year we we have a I think more
than any other show probably uh a reset
of um the sets because uh they were
always evolving and going to new places
so the really exciting thing this season
is to see how those few small rooms that
were the Mars base of Happy Valley in
season 3 that we left those people
strand in on Mars how that's become a
really
thriving uh Mars base with hundreds of
people living and working there um that
uh process of building those sets uh and
figuring out well how would all these
people live together you know would
there be would it all be on the surface
would there be some something that isn't
on the surface you know what what rooms
would the Russians have built versus
Americans have built versus SpaceX sorry
versus Helios having built whoops slip
um so you know that was really fun to
see like well what would the aesthetic
differences be there's a there's a
particular module uh in the Mars base
that's sort of the Soviet contribution
to the expansion of the base um that's
kind of their opcom uh room that uh you
know it was fun to explore well how
would Soviet
architecture and design have changed the
look of what is essentially a technical
space is there anything that you've
wanted to do on the show that you've not
been able to because of just budgetary
reasons like you had an idea or an arc
you're like this would be amazing and we
definitely don't have the money
no I have to say uh you know we I think
we this is probably why we've aged so
much through this uh process of the show
it's a very challenging show but I think
we the Big Ideas we've had we have been
able to accomplish you know and I think
part of that even this season you know I
think the yes there's always little
story arcs or little things we wanted to
do that we can't do right but sometimes
those limitations or budgetary
limitations end up with the most
creative you know creative uh Solutions
in terms of Storytelling so I think our
philosophy is we go into the
room anything goes let's go big and then
we'll figure out how to do it and I
think it's a testament to our crew and
our line producer that we're able to
accomplish those things you know I think
the the big thing this season that was
very new for us was shooting in Eastern
Europe you know we wanted to capture
Margo's experience in Russia and we felt
that you cannot do that in Los Angeles
um so for us it was a very big change
for the show to at the end of the season
go find a location in Eastern Europe
that could fill in for you know alt
history Soviet Union of the era um and
and do it it's almost we brought in some
of our crews some of our cast but most
of it is all new people who've never
worked on the show before it was quite a
change for us it was quite a challenge
but I think that answers your question
about you know we felt we had to figure
out a way to make that happen there were
challenges in doing it but now looking
at season 4 I'm so thrilled that we were
able to go there and pull that off
because it really does feel like a new
world on the show going there well
especially and again no spoilers but
you're in buildings that clearly are not
in Los Angeles and I was actually
wondering about that so how long did you
actually get to film in Eastern Europe
like how long was that location filming
it was uh I think almost a month of
shooting a little shorter than a month
um in February obviously it there's snow
everywhere it looks freezing because it
was freezing um but you're right like it
was very important to us to shoot on
location in these places that you just
cannot replicate um and not only the
buildings but the actors like you just
have access to a whole different uh type
of actor that looks and feels of that
place and time uh and it really brings
again this sense of grounded realism to
those moments that um is really
important to the show Absolutely and and
as I was watching it I'm like wait what
you know because it's so it was clearly
not La um so I question at some point
this series is going to end I'll be
upset but I want to know have you asked
apple and been like hey if this is the
last season can you like tell us so we
can do an ending that like where we want
to end it have you had that conversation
with them because you know like it would
be weird to end on a cliffhanger of
season 4 and then you know not have any
sort of resolution I agree I don't it's
something that I don't love in shows I
watch I we haven't had that conversation
because to be honest Apple's been very
supportive of the show and very
supportive of of the original pitch we
had of going that going that distance um
you know so we've been fortunate that
the show has been received well by fans
of you know people who watch Apple
people don't watch apple and clearly
that more and more people have caught on
to the show over the seasons so I think
as long as people watch it we'll be able
to continue and finish the story we want
to tell and all we've heard from Apple
is you know positive support and
reinforcing the idea that they they also
want us to finish this Arc um so I don't
want to think negative thoughts of not
being able to do that you know but but
that's really for us you know always
been the goal you know let let us get to
the end of this let's tell the story as
we intended do you guys actually have
the end of the arc that you're trying to
say already figured out like the last
shot or the last thing or do you sort of
just have a an idea of where you're
going we have some ideas of of shots and
moments that whether they wind up being
the uh the last actually the last shot
or moment uh remains to be seen because
you never know what's going to change
but we've definitely thought through to
a fairly specific degree how to bring it
to a close so uh obviously the writer
strike happened we everyone knows and
the actors are still on strike but um
before the strike happened on July 1 how
much had you guys been working on the
writing of season
five you're so clever in how you do that
I gotta give you credit you you you like
slide it
in I've been listen I I don't know if
you know this I've been doing collider
for 18 years and I've done an awful lot
of interviews and um you know um hey we
have not officially gotten a season five
pickup oh I we we do want Apple to talk
to our agent manager
Steve so that we can get that process
started as soon as sir I I am well aware
that they have not announced season five
but I'm also aware that all the
streamers um are they have writers rooms
that go uh usually as soon as the the
previous season ends just in case they
want to do the next season it it it
expedites the process it's how you guys
have been able to put a show on
basically every year well and and it's
interesting because I think the
difference this year because of the
writer strike we weren't able to do that
so we weren't able to start a room for
right for season five so which you know
I think you're right that's that's
usually how it works on a show like ours
where you would have to start the room
before the next season uh premieres I
think this is the first time in the
history of the show where the show is
premiering without us really starting a
room for season five so not only do we
not have an official pickup we we
haven't even started uh the room yet and
you know in a way I think that's that's
because of the strike I think we had to
hold off and I think it was the right
move and hopefully you know hopefully we
can get that pickup and continue to tell
the story well one of the things that I
think the one of the problems with
streaming is that often you have a very
big gap between seasons and it really
really destroys the momentum of a show
because I'm not sure about you guys but
when it's been two and a half years
since I saw the last season I don't care
as much like I'm just not as invested
and and one of the secrets of For All
Mankind is it's it's been every year
that there's a season so you just keep
on you know you're you're so invested so
I guess my question is if Apple calls
you and says hey um we want to do season
five how long does a writer room
typically take like if you guys just
like if they called you and said let's
set this up is it like four or five
months of writing before you can be
filming is it longer like what ises that
kind of time frame look yeah it's about
that uh you know but but actually the
the real uh hurdle to our show in
particular and shows like it is the
visual effects process um uh the visual
effects take so long to do and the
reason they look so good is because they
take so long to make to do it right yeah
to do it right so like I our line
producer Seth Edelstein I don't remember
which season this was he went after we
finished shooting our show he went to
work on he produced hacks and uh that
show aired before our show but they shot
it after our show because they don't
have all the visual effects to do so
it's kind of baked into the show on a
certain level I agree with you that that
the amount of time between a show uh
shows season airing can impact how much
people are engaged um and know that Ben
and I are doing everything we can to
make that as small as possible uh within
the limitations of what our show what it
takes to make our show because we also
want it to be as good as it as every
other season has been in terms of the
the level of the visual effects and the
storytelling and how it's shot I you
know something I I totally understand I
think that in this particular instance
with the strikes yeah every show every
single thing from movies to television
is g to be impacted by six months so no
one has a has a has a cheat code to get
past this you know my feeling is like
okay it's the end of October as we talk
God willing you know the SAG strike ends
and you can be God willing filming in
April R you know this is just a
guesstimate but you know like there's no
way the show's on and if you happen to
get a season five pickup please Apple um
I mean there's no way it'll be on until
2025 there's there's physically no way
yeah I me you know I think I think look
the thing that happened with the strike
was necessary you know it had to happen
and there are consequences to those
things you know so I think you're right
it affected all almost every show and I
think audiences now are a little more
forgiving you know I think people are a
little more engaged now they know they
know what happened with the writer
strike and the SAG strike I think
there's an understanding now that there
will be delays on certain shows not
coming back as quickly as they did that
it won't be the same so I think in this
next year I think people understand why
there are those delays but but to me the
key is you know especially with our show
it's you know you can always go back and
watch the last season catch up right
rewatch season 3 I mean that's the thing
you know our show is almost like an
anthology in that way where you can see
the the show the past Seasons again
before the next season shows up and
there's a lot of TV out there right now
so I think I think that opportunity is
there where that you can I hope that our
delay isn't as big as some of these
other shows we actually pride ourselves
on having as small a window between
Seasons as possible but some of these
delays on other shows that are really
huge are getting getting longer and
longer you know so I agree with you it's
a problem but it's kind of a first world
problem totally but it also comes down
to which networks and shows are allowing
a writer's room to continue the second
after you RP and which ones are like
we'll figure it out later because it
when you have those writer rooms going
it really expedites the process but I'm
looking at the clock and I'm realizing
something so good news for fans assuming
you get season five this show will be
airing into 2024 season 4 and in
actuality season five if you get the
green light will absolutely air in
2025 because of so it's really only
going to it will be the next year it'll
just be a long distance between the
beginning of 2024 and the ending of
2025 yeah pretty much yeah I'm just
doing the math in my head and I'm like
I'm just trying to put it together so I
know you guys are 247 on this show is it
one of these situations where you are
still so much enjoying it or are you
also at the same time like trying to
write other things while this is going
on to produce you know what I mean or
like like because how does that work um
for you guys no it's uh it's you're
right it is a 247 job and honestly more
than 247 on this show um but I think for
Ben and I like we can't help but think
about other things and and it's almost
like
a a weird kind of fun spit from the show
to explore other
ideas um you know there's nothing that's
necessarily like in the works right now
but we're always thinking about uh
what's over the next Horizon and what
things uh Intrigue us and get us
creatively inspired um so you know this
show is so specific in its uh Science
Focus but it's also and its history
focus and all that stuff so you know I
think uh we're having started in comedy
we're always people who who look at
uh different genres different types of
Storytelling in ways that that we find
really compelling so I think in addition
to For All Mankind we're excited to find
those next things that that will um
allow us to do different types of shows
yeah I'm curious if you're thinking
about movies as something in the future
or do you like the the genre of
Television where you can really spend so
much time with characters you know
because you you you you know movies are
very tough It's spectacle versus yeah
sometimes substance yeah no I think you
know I don't think we'd say not to
movies but I agree with you I think our
most of our focus is on television and
it's something that we've worked on now
for you know almost 20 years like I
think being able to tell the story over
years with characters and in this show
over people's lifetimes is a unique
opportunity we don't take for granted I
think I think that's the thing with
writers that we're you know a lot of
times being a writing team also you know
we have the ability to you have to have
the ability to focus on more than one
thing at a time you know so I think
sometimes yes while this show is
all-encompassing I think it's important
in our career and in any writer's career
to be thinking ahead you know even the
writers in our in our show we encourage
them to be working on their own Pilots
while they're Staffing on our show
because we know that for writer to
succeed to keep to keep growing as a
writer you need to keep working on your
own thing so so the idea that like if
you're not focused on only the thing
you're working on then you're not able
to do it I think is is wrongheaded and I
don't think it's it's a smart move for
any writer so usually it's about 10
years in between every season uh should
I assume if you do five and season six
or even seven is it always going to be
like a 10-year thing or have you ever do
you have the idea to make a bigger jump
in the future I think uh you know
definitely uh like Ben said at one point
uh the idea of getting up to the present
uh in our show is something that's so
compelling to us uh where a season is
set in the year it airs so that when the
viewer is looking around at the world
that they're in and then the world that
could have been on the screen it really
like nails the kind of
the promise of the premise of our show
in a real big way but as I was saying
earlier also you know expectation is
kind of the um you know the enemy of of
good storytelling on a certain level and
so I don't think we're we would rule out
uh something like that at some point in
the show either so have you figured out
what the Starship will look
like well it's probably gonna be a dis
that's sort of you know turned flat and
uh it sort of look like this office I'm
in right now very very listen when you
have Ron Moore as someone who works you
know one of the main people um or you
know producer I'm not exactly sure what
Ron does on a day-to-day basis I think
he's an executive producer whatever um
but I mean when he's involved you know
you can't help but talk Star Trek SL
Starships well it's interesting you know
Ron is always involved in the show but
he obviously co-created this with us and
I think as much as he's part of that
world in was in Star Trek and Battle
Star he's also like us very intrigued in
other genres you know he also did
Outlander and he develops other things
so I think I think it's a testament to
him as a writer but also you know to
kind of what we did with this show is
the idea of you know now more than ever
television doesn't have to be just so
genr specific I me you're seeing TV
shows now that have comedy even though
they're dramas or are sci-fi but you
know period like so I think I think the
good thing about where television is and
I hope continues to be is the ability to
tell stories that aren't just specific
to one genre or one type um and I think
that's something that you know Ron Matt
and I early on saw with this show you
know that that it was hard to Define and
I think that's a good thing not
necessarily a bad thing last question
for you guys and you've been very
generous with your time uh is there any
technology or advances that have been
you've seen in the real world that
you're like oh yes we need to use that
that's a that's a
stumper uh you know I think I don't know
if there's a specific thing although
there's lots of of things as we each
season in the way we brought in nuclear
fusion or or um you know uh um these
different types of engines um but what
we're always more than the technology I
think what we're super interested in is
how technology changes society and how
uh people behave differently based on
technology and how it can shift things
and I think AI obviously is the touch
word now in technology uh of how that is
about to shift our world in big ways
that everybody's intrigued by and scared
by and um you know in the For All
Mankind world I don't know we haven't
figured out yet how something like that
fits in um but what it's really what
it's got us think about is how does
really big fundamental Technologies like
that shift the world in a big way um
that is kind of one of the uh the the
secret weapons of our show is exploring
ideas like that and I'll add to that
like I think what's interesting too the
you know this is the first time in many
ways like the asteroid mission's
happening right now with that the psyche
Mission literally launched the day our
trailer dropped um so there's an
interplay there that's interesting of
you know here we are doing a season
focused on mining asteroids as I think
this interest in asteroids is happening
literally as we speak um is booming so I
think the timing of that is is great for
two is for our show but also it speaks
to to what Matt was saying this idea of
you know the science you know we're
getting photos from Mars as we're doing
VFX on the show and looking at how to
color the landscape we're actually
getting photos from Mars every day and
discussing them with j red or VFX
supervis and going like oh what about
this what about this color look this is
how a sunset looks on Mars so that
ability to take actual science that's
that's happening in real time and have
it impact the show is really special and
it's something we don't take for granted
and I think it's something we're going
to continue to do you know so the this
Resurgence of interest in space travel
happening as the show keeps growing has
really been uh fortuitous I think for us
yeah I just want to point out for people
that haven't uh looked there you can go
online and and and watch actual video
from Mars with the actual audio from the
the you know the Rover that NASA or
whoever put up there and it's insane
that there is something you can just do
on your computer you know what I mean
like just go to Mars and just watch
video and listen to the planet it's it's
just it's insane that this is just a
normal thing yeah yeah so agree it's
anyway I'm floored by it which is why I
know all those people at Nasa are
watching For All Mankind there's no no
doubt in my mind anyway listen gentlemen
I really want to say congrats on the
series you know how much I love it and I
really do hope you get to tell the full
Arc of what you want to do and I look
forward to talking spoilers with you uh
later on because I avoided everything
during this conversation you did a great
job uh thank you and we can't wait to to
keep the conversation going we love uh
everything you do and uh uh and this was
fun
conversation